so this is it the second round of this
divisive election is underway and
they've been out very early over 120
million Brazilians are expected to vote
in this contest that's gone to a second
round because neither the incumbent Jeb
bolsonaro or it would be successor Lula
de Silva secured the vital 50 plus one
vote needed to win outright
both sides need as many people as
possible to come out and vote for them
this is such a close election Sao Paulo
for example public transport is now free
to encourage people to go and vote but
as I say it's impossible to call this
one
the two candidates have already cast
their vote in Rio de Janeiro where
president bolsonaro has a home he was
greeted by his supporters at his local
polling station
after voting he told the waiting media
he had an expectation of winning
if God wants we will be victorious this
afternoon actually Brazil will be
victorious this afternoon he said
in Sao Paulo the headquarters of the
Lula campaign the former Brazilian
president was greeted by a static crowd
they chanted his name as he waved now he
and Mr bolzanaro can do nothing but wait
for the results
it's knife edge stuff and neither side
is confident
many are very sophisticated but polls
have been inaccurate
perhaps the street vendors that sell the
presidential merchandise no more than
most
sallow Ariel keeps a tally of the towels
flags and badges he sells it's
unsophisticated but it's probably a good
indicator
material
has claimed the electronic voting system
isn't secure even claiming the election
will be rigged
Lula supporters say that is just a
Donald Trump style strategy
built for Donald Trump yes I mean so the
structure behind it the narratives are
exactly the same so the difference is
that we know now in advance because the
elections in the United States prepared
the groundwork for us to strike back so
the idea is to to have this in mind
their strategy looks very very similar
to the strategy of trump in the last
election so we more or less have an idea
what to expect but we are here exactly
for fighting for democracy
so either of the candidates could win
it's that close they say the problem for
Brazil is that the divisions are so deep
any reconciliation between the two sides
will prove incredibly difficult
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Sao Paulo